okay so today we're going to talk about
hormone and balance okay now just to
make this very complex subject very
simple the endocrine system as a whole
is basically the superior communication
system it has various glands that make
and send hormones through the blood and
hormones our communications so they're
sent received and they transmit back in
kind of a circuit there it's called
feedback loops so that when the
information gets back then the gland can
stop sending that message if there's any
type of problem along this pathway
hormones can actually go up or go down
so we call that hyper or hypo so if it's
too much in the thyroid it'd be a
condition called hyperthyroidism if it's
too low it'll be hypothyroid and it
happens with pretty much all the
different hormones okay they're very
sensitive to the environment especially
chemicals chemicals in our food
medications pesticides insecticides
toxins because a lot of those chemicals
in the environment are called endocrine
disruptors and that's because the glands
and hormones a lot of them are made from
fat and so a lot of chemicals are fat
soluble so they kind of get stuck in
there the receptors and they block it
and they disrupt the normal flow of
communication in the body also there are
other things especially like with the
adrenal hormones that are very sensitive
to stresses emotional stresses losses
physical stresses trauma surgery that
can alter the adrenal gland as far as
estrogen goes the ovary is very
sensitive to things in our food
especially hormones so if you're
consuming commercial dairy for example
that has hormones and has other
chemicals growth hormones it can be
greatly influenced also birth control
pills hormonal replacement therapy back
in the 50s there was something called
des diethylstilbestrol and that was a
very powerful estrogen that was supposed
to prevent miscarriages until they found
out 30 years later it causes
miscarriages
okay so create a lot of problems of
they kept it on the market for ten years
later and for giving it to animals and
of course that you were eating the
animals so if you were born before 1979
you probably were exposed to it and it
creates a lot of problems with our own
body GMO foods has the herbicide called
glyphosate which also creates a lot of
problems within our endocrine system as
well when you go through menopause you
have this backup organ to the ovaries
which is the adrenal glands and if the
adrenal glands are not functioning if
they're weak and if they're stressed if
they're fatigued going through menopause
then it can't act as a backup to the
ovaries because the adrenal glands make
the same hormones in the ovaries and
they're meant to back it up not in the
same amounts that you actually have when
you're not in menopause but the fact is
if that backup does not occur then you
get symptoms of deficiencies or
sometimes even excess amounts of
hormones because estrogen works with
progesterone so I don't wanna get into
that complexity but I just want to let
you know there's a lot of things that
can interfere with the gland and so when
dealing with either a hyper or hypo
hormone a lot of times that you can get
lost in the forest you have to take a
bird's-eye view and look at the whole
scene and I recommend support the gland
not the hormone because the hormone is
just a communication it does what the
gland
tells it to do so a lot of people kind
of ignore the gland itself and they
don't actually support like the adrenal
gland for example they're trying to
manipulate the end product down here in
the chain of events the thyroid is
usually secondary to other things
because you have the situation where the
thyroid produces hormones but they're
inactive they're t4 they don't really do
anything unless they're activated
through the liver and gallbladder and
the kidney so 80% of thyroid hormone t4
it has to be converted into an active
form t3 through that those two things
mainly the liver and gallbladder but
about 20% through the kidney so if you
have a fatty liver or a cirrhosis of the
litter or inflammatory State of the
liver hepatitis or you
a gallbladder or you're missing bile or
if you have any problem in that area
boom tharra problem hypo also if you
have too much estrogen okay say you have
a hyper estrogen situation that could
actually inhibit the thyroid hormone or
you're taking birth control pills or
hormone replacement therapy or consuming
a lot of soy which can mimic estrogen
that can inhibit thyroid function if you
have Hashimoto's which is really not a
classic thyroid problem it's an
autoimmune it's an immune problem that
just so happens to be attacking a
thyroid that's a completely different
situation you have networks of
antioxidants that is made by your body
and also you can take them from get them
from the food and so you have this
constant battle of your own cells
killing off microbes making things to
kill off microbes and foreign pathogens
and so those are like hydrogen peroxide
for example that would be one of them
your body makes it to kill off these
microbes well if there's a breakdown in
the antioxidant system of your body and
maybe you're not consuming enough from
the diet as well that alone can cause a
buildup of hydrogen peroxide and that
can damage your thyroid and in which
case you have to restore that system
again to actually kind of counter that
now I have individual videos on each
thing so you can look that up and I'm
just kind of giving you an overview of
what can happen but so it's really rare
to have a primary thyroid it's usually
secondary from something else okay when
you go to the doctor always dig in and
find out what causes the problem ask
them like what could be underneath this
don't just buy well things just happen
for no reason and you just have to be
very unlucky try to find out what causes
it especially if they want to treat it
because a lot of times they treat it
they treat a secondary problem and they
leave the primary problem alone they
don't look at it and then you never get
better all right let's get to
testosterone and I'm gonna mainly focus
on females for this okay what you need
to know about testosterone is that if a
woman has too much testosterone and
we're going to call it androgen
many times that can come from not
necessarily being exposed to in urgence
but basically having too much insulin
okay it's more dietary from too many
carbs or too too much frequent eating so
you might think well wow I'm like am I
getting antigen from the from the
outside from something no no it's being
converted from another hormone so that's
what makes things very confusing the
other thing you need to know is that
your adrenal glands in addition to the
ovary makes testosterone so if you have
a hyperactive adrenal gland from some
reason that alone could spike your
androgens as well okay so now let's take
it back to cortisol let's just kind of
cover if you have too much cortisol
you're gonna get belly fat allergies
diabetes because high cortisol breaks
down protein your own body and your body
will start making more sugar as well and
you're gonna basically either turn your
own muscle protein into sugar or your
liver is gonna make more sugar because
cortisol is called a glucocorticoid it's
a hormone that makes glucose so this
alone can spike insulin you can become
diabetic just from having high cortisol
or even taking prednisone which is a
medication of a synthetic version of
cortisol racing mind where you're
thinking analyzing things 24/7 that
happens and eventually you start having
memory loss when that happens so it
keeps you kind of in a flight or fight
mode high blood pressure high
cholesterol probably from the chain
reaction from the high insulin and then
we have low vitamin D levels how many
people have low vitamin D I mean it's
like across the board round-faced or
rosacea which is kind of a red cheek
situation low tolerance to stress you
can also have all sorts of immune
problems with white blood cells but I
don't want to keep it simple alright
hypo low cortisol here are the symptoms
poor immune system virus is coming out
of remission weight loss you start
losing weight okay you might say wow
that's a great thing but it's probably
not because you're not gonna actually be
healthy it's not the healthiest
wait yeah you your skin becomes a little
bit darker like you get a tan again not
this is not healthy vitiligo which is
those little white spots or a loss of
pigment on the on the skin because
cortisol does influence the melanin salt
cravings you're going to be losing a lot
of salt if you don't have enough
cortisol and also enough adrenal
hormones there's other hormones involved
so you're gonna be basically taking all
the salt all the time and you actually
need it
estrogen hypo that means low estrogen
depression dry skin zero libido hot
flashes night sweats poor memory
insomnia vaginal dryness other than that
you're perfectly fine then we have a
hyper estrogen state that's too much we
call that estrogen dominance breast
tenderness would be one symptom enlarged
breasts fibrocystic breasts which are
cysts in the breast or cysts in the
ovary and this is why sea kelp what
works for that because the iodine helps
to regulate and lower excess amounts of
estrogen fluid retention heavy cycles
okay excessive bleeding then you get
anemia from that heavy cramping weight
gain in lower part of your body the hips
the butt in the thighs saddlebags PMS
again other than that you're good to go
I would probably avoid dairy if you have
any problems with the ovary it's
probably gonna help you especially if
you have a fibroid for example now if
you're going through menopause and you
have estrogen problems you should
probably support the adrenal because
that's the backup organ with that and
then if you're on birth control pills
just realize that can be a contributing
factor and you really want to do organic
non-gmo because of the chemicals
involved so you have to eat really clean
if you have this problem here now as far
as the thyroid goes if you're a hypo not
enough thyroid you're gonna be tired
depressed dry skin dry hair loss of
eyebrows okay associate in the outer
part I don't think I have a problem with
that okay brittle hair hot flashes
night sweats weight gain all over not in
any location because the thyroid hormone
innervates pretty much every single cell
and it increases mitochondria which
control the metabolism that's why you're
gonna have a slow metabolism and that's
why you kind of gain weight everywhere
cuz everything kind of sluggish
constipation
that's hypo high burn too much thyroid
excess sweating nervous you're hyper
hyper 8 you have these protruding
eyeballs insomnia your cycle goes away
and you lose weight ok now let's talk
about testosterone in women by the way
hypo
hair loss decreased sex drive depression
fatigue and you can see fatigue is kind
of a common thread with everything and
this is why when people are fatigued you
really have to look at the whole thing
because you can be fatigued from so many
things loss of just drive your
get-up-and-go mojo has gone and left the
building
vaginal dryness weight gain okay hyper
too much testosterone okay again this is
probably coming from high levels of
insulin or could be coming from an
overactive adrenal but you can have hair
loss acne deeper voice facial hair
polycystic ovarian syndrome okay so I
just wanted to kind of give you an
overview of what can happen to the
endocrine system some of the symptoms
with high too much or too little of a
hormone okay so now that you kind of
have a summary it's a little complex but
the real important thing to do before
you start diving down and taking
remedies and supplements for any of this
you have to get your basic eating
corrected you have to clean up your
eating to the point where you're not
doing any chemicals in your food that
it's not no longer toxic you eat very
very healthy foods and I have a video
down below of what to eat but get that
in first for a while and then see if
enemies are still there alright thanks
for watching
so I want to know about what you think
about this video
so please comment below and tell me what
you think